wohl eine chance erhält jetzt einmal
kommen zunächst ein foto das ist nicht
[Musik]
willkommen beim ein video ja leute mich
weit so der hintergrund der ist noch
nicht so geil wir wurden auch echte
schlange hier also gerade mal seit 35
tagen oder so und dementsprechend sich
dann auch hieraus wäre jetzt wenigstens
die lampe oder so wäre das gar kein
problem dann wird wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen schöner aus dem problem ist nur
wir haben noch keine lampen der leute
strom ist aber da also ich glaube das
riecht es ganz cool und ich lasse mir
natürlich nicht nehmen hier für euch ein
video zu drehen auch wenn wir glaubten
umzugsstress noch sind ich habe mich
heute etwas ganz besonderes überlegt wie
natürlich auch immer und farbe jemand
auf intern geschrieben und meint sich
auch alex macht normalen im video zu
fotos die nur mädchen verstehen also
ziemlich ob video denen über instagram
und die idee fand ich ganz cool so und
deswegen gibt's heute musical wissen wir
nicht was wir machen das also es gibt
halt heute um 10 fotos die fliege die
wirklich nur mädchen verstehen also ich
bin mal gespannt
ich glaube ich bin ja ein halbes mädchen
deswegen verstehe ist die bestimmte
außen zwar ist natürlich nur spaß
ich würde sagen fangen an mit dem ersten
bild und zwar ist dass das hier also
ohne die überschrift jetzt mal zu lesen
würde ich sagen da hat ihr mann starke
weint oder erteilt mit wasser in kontakt
gekommen also ich finde das sollte jeder
verstehen wenn user und make up on als
wenn du unter die dusche ist mit make-up
tiefer danach echt so schlimm
also ich kann es jetzt natürlich nicht
beurteilen ohne wird es gibt so viele
menschen youtuber die sich schminken
bevor sie ein video drehen
ich habe mich echt doch nie geschminkt
etwas recht egal das habe ich auf jeden
fall sofort verstanden das nächste mal
statt hier und da drüber steht heißt
also ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau
ich hab so noch ein bisschen in
erinnerungen irgendwie so von wegen wenn
du ganz genau vettel muss aber dir
gerade seine fingernägel lackiert hat
ich frage mich so jedoch einfach auf
toilette dann gehst du hast das du hast
du nie was man muss hier die hose
aufmachen das muss ich jetzt mal kurz
fest wenn es nicht geht so ich david mit
meinen fingernägeln nicht in berührung
mit meiner hose kommen wir nehmen hier
das t-shirt hoch
es wird investiert und dann nimmt man
die hose und macht sie auf ok hat recht
es könnte echt schwer werden weil dann
hat man natürlich alles voll mit
nagellack habe ich auch was dann also
ich glaube ich würde das hinbekommen
aber ich sage ja meine nägel ich kombi
zunächst ein foto das kenn ich habe auch
so eine brille die heißen irgendwie
porno bringen war so und das ding ist
die verfangen sich ja echt immer den
haaren wenn man die man hier darüber
macht also wenn man die hoch macht dann
wieder runter machen will ist selbst bei
mir so dass man die daraus ziehen muss
weil die sicherheit hier drin verfangen
hat aber natürlich logisch desto längere
haare man hat desto einfacher kann die
sich darin verfangen und desto heftiger
kann sich darin verfangen deswegen also
ich verstehe das bild eines der drei
bilder angeschaut und ich habe
eigentlich jedes verstanden so kommen
zum nächsten bild ich kann jetzt gar
nicht so genau hin was darauf passiert
eben was ist mit den haar haid falls
also die haare haben sich irgendwie in
irgendetwas verfangen das ist bestimmt
dieses diese spange die man da so drauf
macht wenn man jetzt einen job hat oder
so und wenn sich dann die haare so
zusammen drehen das rudern sie das
irgendwann so aus es kann natürlich sein
ob ich damit jetzt richtig oder falsch
liege keine ahnung also an die mädchen
was hat es mit diesem bild auch nicht
schreibt es mir bitte in die kommentare
also
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er ist dass ihr zeit nur heute schon
wieder hält jetzt einmal kommen zunächst
ein foto das ist nicht
[Applaus]
so kommen zum nächsten foto und zwar ist
es dass hier ohne die jungs hätte ich es
echt nicht verstünden aber mit der
überschrift verstehe ich das glaube ich
weil wenn man sein sein soll er also zu
eng macht dann wird das gesicht der
automat ich weiß ganz schließt erklären
soll aber ich hoffe ihr versteht mich
ist wie wenn jemand jetzt alle meine
haare nehmen würde und sogar anziehen
würde
dann wird man ja auch so denken passiert
halt so immer was mache ich gehörte
versteht ihr was ich euch sagen möchte
also ich finde das wirklich witzig wenn
ihr pony testtag könnte auch den titel
von pornos einheit ohne polizei oder mit
[Musik]
um ehrlich ich stehe heute nacht und 3
block und setzt auch ein bohrer da an
die wand und wurde immer schön was so
läuft das nicht so will ist dieser
wunderbare stuhl
ok also wir haben jetzt einen stuhl und
oben ist ein roter kreis rum also das
obere vom schultes eingekreist irgendwas
muss ja damit auch nicht haben was es
jetzt genau ist fragt mich nicht also
das ist jetzt wenigstens erste bild
durchsagen muss keine ahnung und ich
freue mich darauf versteht dass wirklich
jedes mädchen was ist mit diesem stuhl
auf sich hat schreibst du auf jeden fall
in die kommentare
ich bin gespannt vielleicht denke ich
kann auch einfach nur zu kompliziert
oder ich habe wirklich keine ahnung wir
kommen zum nächsten bild james the witch
project ja da habe ich meine ernsthafte
frage und war
was denkt ihr denn wie das aussieht wenn
man den neuen mathelehrerin bekommt den
namen absolut vorher noch nie gehört hat
keine ahnung wer ist in einer klasse
sitzen 15 jungen diese mathelehrerin
kommt rein und die mathelehrerin ist
verdammt geil glaubt ihr das dann zum
beispiel max nicht aus dass
lieblingssatz in jedem jungwirth was nur
wirklich schade ich hatte in meiner
gesamten schullaufbahn nicht eine
lehrerin sich aktiv beachten oder hatten
wir irgendwie lehrern auf unserer schule
die heiß war nicht wirklich wo man sagen
kann es war mein größter und komme zum
letzten biss nee du kannst doch nicht
sein kommt bloß ganz wer jetzt aber sei
mit dir mit weiterdrehen
jetzt gehts ja aber ich bin jetzt anders
als wenn man sich das buch mal genau
anschaut ich habe auf jeden fall eine
theorie und zwar wird probiert wie der
nagellack aussieht also ist kennst ja
auch ich habe verdammt viel nagellack zu
hause oder wenn man halt neuer
nagellacken zukunft muss man erstmal
hier so gucken wie das wirklich aussieht
als wie die farbe aussieht und wenn man
dann 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 mal
den nagellack getestet hat dann kann man
schauen welcher sieht am besten aus und
dann kommt dieses bild zustande
ich würde sagen wenn es jetzt die
richtige theorie war allemal sofort nach
oben bestimmt dankeschön er leute so
vielleicht mal dazu wenn ihr noch einen
zweiten teil haben wollt ihr könnt auch
gerne tores das schicke einfach
integrieren da hat sie auch einfach eine
knie- oder selbst kann
ein supertor instagram wir sehen uns
ansonsten übermorgen wieder da kommt
neues video
lasst dann nach oben auf jeden fall
apple jünger macht haut rein